[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مفاوضات مكثفه وحثيفه بين
الدول العربيه تجري وراء الكواليس لاعاده
العلاقات مع الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
المفاوضات متعدده المسارات التفاصيل كثيره
لان الملف السوري لا يهم فقط دول الجوار
ولكن كل دول المنطقه بما فيها الدول الغير
العربيه ران وتركيا واسرائيل والقول
الكبرى الولايات المتحده الاتحاد الاوروبي
روسيا الصين الى اخره وعليه يمكن ان نناقش
هذا الملف من زوايا مختلفه في حلقات مقبله
لكن في هذه الحلقه نسعى الاجابه على
سؤالين تحديدا السؤال الاول لماذا تتزعم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الكارهه لبشار
الاسد
حمله التطبيع معه والسؤال الثاني لماذا
تعارض وتتحفظ دول عربيه مثل قطر والمغرب
واليمن اعاده العلاقات على اعاده العلاقات
مع بشار الاسد حتى هذه اللحظه والسؤال
الثالث ما هو حقيقه الموقف المصري قبل
محاوله الاجابه على كل هذه الاسئله
اذكركم بخلفيه الاحداث وكيف وصلنا الى هنا
المساله بدات طبعا مع ثورات الربيع العربي
اللي انتقلت مظاهرات واحتجاجاته من تونس
لمصر لدول عربيه اخرى من بينها سوريا
بدايه من مارس 2011 اتسعت الاحتجاجات
وواجه بشار الاسد هذه الاحتجاجات بعنف
شديد متهما المحتجين بانهم ليسوا الا
عملاء لقوى خارجيه ترغب في هدم استقرار
الدوله السوريه والتامر على النظام الحاكم
هناك الدول العربيه وخصوصا الدول الخليجيه
راقبت ما يجري في البدايه بهدوء حذر ثم
سرعان ما انتقلت الى معسكر المؤيدين
للمعارضه والراغبين في الاطاحه بنظام بشار
الاسد وكان هذا الموقف مبني على اعتبارينا
اساسيين الاعتبار الاول هو العنف الشديد
جدا الذي استخدمه بشار الاسد
لكن السبب الاهم كان علاقه بشار الاسد
بمصدر التهديد الاساسي لدول الخليج وهي
ايران بشار الاسد ومن قبله ابيه حافظ
الاسد كان كان وما زال حليفا اساسيا
لايران التي تمثل اكبر مصدر للتهديد
والخطر على استقرار دول الخليج على الاقل
في حينها
وعليه فانه الدول الخليجيه رات في تطور
الاحداث فرصه لتقليص النفوذ الايراني
باسقاط نظام بشار الاسد كانت الحزبه اذا
تمكنا من اسقاط بشار الاسد الذي كان في
موقف ضعيف جدا في مواجهه الاحتجاجات
المتسعه
والتخلص منه خصوصا ان التخلص منهم موضع
ترحيب من الولايات المتحده دول اوروبا
اسرائيل وعليه فليس له حلفاء يمكن لهم ان
ينقذوه واذا حدث ذلك سوف
ياتي على انقاد النظام بشار الاسد نظام
سني سوف يكون بطبيعه الحال حليفه لدول
الخليج وخصما او يعني
معاديا لايران او على الاقل ليس حليفا لها
اذكركم ايضا انه ما حدث في سوريا كانت له
ابعاد اخرى دول الخليج كانت تراقب يجري في
سوريا في 2011 وهي تشعر بالخصه بالغصه من
الانتصارات الايرانيه المتواليه على
الساحه على ساحه الاقليم يعني سبق هذه
الاحداث
هزيمه للدول العربيه في الملف العراقي
شعرت الدول الخليجيه تحديدا ان ايران
هزمتها ببسط نفوذها على العراق على حساب
المصالح الخليجيه لما تولى نور المالكي
الحليف الايراني بامتياز مقاليد السلطه
هناك بدايه من 2006 واستمر 2014 خساره
العراق لم يكن امرا سهلا على الدول
الخليجيه وعلى الدول العربيه بصفه عامه
الامر الثاني انه السابق الانتصار
الايراني في الساحه العراقيه انتصارا طبعا
في الملف اللبناني حيث حزب الله الحريف
الايراني وصاحب الكلمه الاولى والاخيره في
الملف اللبناني وبالتالي المصالح الخارجيه
كانت في خطر
سبق الملفين نجاح ايران في تعضيض وتوثيق
علاقتها بالجماعات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه خصوصا حماس وجماعه الجهاد
وكانت هناك بشائر الاضطرابات في اليمن
تظهر لي صناع القرار في دول الخليج جماعه
الحوثي وحلفائه القريبين الى حد ما وقتها
من ايران بداوا يظهروا في الصوره ما كان
ينظر بخطر ايضا لدول الخليج لكل هذه
الاسباب لم تكتفي السعوديه ودول الخليج
بتجميد عضويه سوريا بدايه من 16 نوفمبر
2011 ولا بقطع العلاقات مع بشار الاسد
ولكنهم سعوا السعوديه والدول الخليجيه
اخرى مثل قطر والامارات تحديدا سعوا
للاطاحه ببشار الاسد باستخدام القوه وط
بعا اصبحت تفاصيل تفاصيل محاوله هذه الدول
بالتحالف والتنسيق مع تركيا ومع الولايات
المتحده ومع دول اخرى اصبحت معروفه ولم
تعد سرا وعلى كل الاحوال بعيدا عن
التفاصيل والاسرار تصريح واحد لوزير
الخارجيه السعودي علنا يمكن ان يوضح هذه
الحقيقه دون اي يعني
دون اي غموض في 14 نوفمبر 2015 قال وزير
الخارجيه
السعودي انذاك عادل الجبير اذا فشلت
العمليه السياسيه في الاطاحه بالاسد فان
الرياض سوف تواصل دعم المعارضه من اجل
ازاحته بالقوه
استمرت دول الخليج وعلى راسها السعوديه في
دعم الجماعات المسلحه ضد بشار الاسد حاولت
دول اخرى الولايات المتحده تركيا قصه باتت
معروفه لكن تدخلت ايران تدخلت روسيا
بعد عده سنوات انتصر معسكر روسيا ايران
بشار الاسد كما بات معروفا الان ولاسباب
يعني عالجناها كثيرا وعالجها غيرنا يعني
الحرب انتهت بمعسكر فائز ومعسكر خاسر
المعسكر الفائز معسكر بشار ايران روسيا
المعسكر الخاسر دول الخليج معظم الدول
العربيه تركيا الولايات المتحده الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذا هو المعسكر الخاسر
مع خساره الحرب في سوريا
ويعني تبخر فكره الاطاحه ببشار الاسد الذي
اصبح امرا واقعا واصبح نجا من الاطاحه او
انهيار النظام وناجا واصبح ايضا قادرا على
السيطره على معظم الاراضي السوريه وليس كل
الاراضي السوريه انقسم المعسكر المهزوم في
سوريا الى
اتجاهين اساسيين اتجاه يرى ضروره الاعتراف
بالامر الواقع والتصالح مع بشار الاسد
وقاد هذا المعسكر الامارات العربيه
والبحرين ومعسكر اخر يرى ضروره الاستمرار
والضغط على نظام بشار الاسد ولكل منهم
منطقه المنطق الاماراتي البحريني
اللي طبعا كانت بتدعمه دول كانت من
البدايه لا ترغب في الاطاحه ببشار الاسد
زي الجزائر على سبيل المثال وزي مصر التي
ارادت التصالح مع بشار الاسد وعدم الضغط
عليه من وقت مبكر من 2014 و 2015 كان منطق
الامارات والبحرين انه بما انه بشار الاسد
اصبح امرا واقعا وبما اننا فشلنا فيه
الاطاحه به فالافضل لنا ان نعيد العلاقات
معه هذا سوف يحقق لنا ثلاثه اهداف الهدف
الاول اذا قعدنا العلاقات مع هذا يعني
اننا سوف نكون قادرين على
يعني حمايه مصالحنا عند تسويه الملف
السوري ما احنا هنحافظ على مصالحنا ازاي
اذا كنا بعيدين تماما على الملف السوري
ثانيا
اذا كانت المشكله هي مشكله النفوذ
الايراني فايران اصبحت ذات نفوذ بالغ في
سوريا هذا النفوذ سوف يزداد قوه الى
واصلنا سياستنا
بتعتمد على عزل سوريا لان بشار الاسد لن
يكون امامه الا ايران وروسيا وبطبيعه
الحال سوف يزداد نفوذ ايران اما اذا فتحنا
له ابوابنا فسوف تقل حاجته لايران
وبالتالي يقل نفوذ ايران تدريجيا في سوريا
السبب الثالث انه سوريا في كل الاحوال سوف
تنتهي يعني ماساتها عاجلا او اجلا وهناك
مزايا اقتصاديه من الانفتاح عليها هو ملف
اعاده الاعمار اللي بتتعطش اليه كثير من
الشركات الخارجيه وغير الخارجيه المعسكر
الرافد الذي كانت تقوده السعوديه يرى انه
صحيح بشار الاسد نجا من عمليه الاطاحه بهم
وانه يبسط سيطرته الان على معظم الاراضي
السوريه وانه انتصر في الحرب بسبب دعم
حليفيه ايران وروسيا
ولكن لا هو ولا ايران ولا روسيا سوف يكون
قادرين على الاستمرار والاستمتاع بهذا
النصر بسبب ظروفهم الاقتصاديه الصعبه جدا
وان استمرار الضغط الدبلوماسي والسياسي
والاقتصادي سوف يؤدي الى انهيار هذا
النظام الذي لن يستطيع ان يستمر في منصبه
اذا ظل السوريون جوعا على كل الاحوال بدات
بدا الانشقاقه واضحا والخلاف على الملف
السوري واضحا الامارات في ديسمبر 2018
اعلنت اعاده العلاقات مع بشار الاسد
واعلنت عن اعاده فتح سفارتها في دمشق
بعدها بيوم واحد فعلت البحرين نفس الشيء
وظلت المملكه العربيه السعوديه متطلبه في
موقفها وكان هذا التصلب احد اسباب فشل
دعوه فشل المحاولات الجزائريه لاعاده
سوريا او دعوه سوريا لمؤتمر الجامعه
العربيه العام الماضي لكن حدث التغيير
المفاجئ على الاقل لغير المراقبين في
فبراير
2023 لما وزير الخارجيه السعودي
الامير فيصل بن فرحان قال في 18 فبراير
2023 الجاري العام الجاري اقصد في خلال
جلسه حواريه في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن ان
اجماعا بدا يتشكل في العالم العربي على
انه لا جدوى من عزل سوريا وان الحوار مع
دمشق مطلوب في وقت ما حتى تتسنى على الاقل
معالجه المسائل الانسانيه بما في ذلك عوده
اللاجئين
وعليه بدات يعني الاشارات تظهر على ان
هناك تغير في الموقف السعودي
وبدات خطوات تمهيديه لاعاده العلاقات بين
سوريا وبين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الخطوات تتابعت بشكل سريع وكان اول هذه
الاشارات وهذه الخطوات اعلان التلفزيون
الرسمي السعودي في وقت متاخر من يوم
الخميس الموافق 22 مارس يعني بعد 12 يوم
فقط من اعاده العلاقات الايرانيه السعوديه
او الاعلان عن اعاده العلاقات
السعوديه الايرانيه في 10 مارس
والتليفزيون قناه الاخباريه السعوديه
اعلنت في مساء هذا اليوم ان هناك محادثات
الاستئناف الخدمات القنصليه بين البلدين
وبدات التسريبات من صحف كثيره تتحدث عن
قرب التطبيع بين الدولتين ثم بدات
الزيارات تتم على مستوى المس الامنيين
ورؤساء المخابرات وفود هنا وفود هناك الى
ان وصلنا مؤخرا في شهر ابريل الماضي الى
زيارات متبادله بين
للعاصمتين وزير الخارجيه السعودي يزور
دمشق وزير الخارجيه السوري يزوروا الرياض
الموقف السعودي يعني اصبح اكثر تطورا
وانتقل من الرغبه في التطبيع الى حماس
لاقناع دول عربيه اخرى بالتطبيع ويجري
مفاوضات ماراثونيه في عواصم عربيه مختلفه
لاقناع الدول المتردده بضروره التطبيع مع
بشار الاسد
وفك تجميد عضويتها في جامعه الدول العربيه
قبل 19 مايو الجاري اليوم الذي سوف يشهد
انعقاد القمه العربيه التي سوف تستفيضه
تستضيفها المملكه العربيه السعوديه يبقى
السؤال لماذا كل هذا الحماس السعودي لماذا
هذا التغير المفاجئ في السياسه السعوديه
الحقيقه في تقديري هناك ثلاث اسباب
الاول والاقل اهميه هو رغبه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ان تكون القمه العربيه
التي سوف تعقد في 19 مايو على اراضيها هي
الانجح بين كل القمم العربيه التي سبقتها
تريد ان تحقق في هذه القمه ما لم تنجح اي
دوله عربيه اخرى في تحقيقه تقدر تضع هذه
الرغبه تحت مظله اوسع وهو ان تعزز صورتها
باعتبارها الدوله الاكثر نفوذا بين الدول
العربيه والاكثر اهميه بين كل الدول
المنطقه العربيه وغير عربيه المملكه
بتستمتع هذه الايام في السنوات الاخيره
بنفوذ لم يسبق للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ابدا ان تمتعت به ده بسبب قوتها
الاقتصاديه المتعاظمه من ناحيه واستقرارها
طبعا لكن ايضا بسبب تراجع نفوذ الدول
المنافسه لها ابرز هذه الدول طبعا على
الاطلاق والدوله اللي كانت بتحظى بهذا
الوضع لسنوات
لكن في سببين اهم من مساله النفوذ ومساله
النفود ليست مساله بسيطه هي
اعتبارين وكلاهما مرتبط بالاخر الاعتبار
الاول الرغبه في الازدهار والامر الثاني
هو تحقيق الامن والاستقرار للدوله
السعوديه
دايما عندها هدف منذ سنوات طويله في اطار
رغبتها في الحفاظ على يعني رخائها وعلى
وضعها كدوله غنيه ده يقتدي ان هي تنوع
مصادر دخلها بعيدا عن البترول معظم الدخل
السعودي ما زال ياتي من البترول والبترول
سوف يظل مصدرا جيدا للدخل لسنوات طويله
لكن في النهايه سوف يعني يعني يختفي كمصدر
رئيسي للدخل وتتراجع عوائده وعليه
فالسعوديه بدات تسعى جديا لتنويع مصادر
دخلها بان هي يكون عندها سياحه مزدهره
تكون مركز للاعمال الطيران تكون مركز
الصناعه وهكذا لكن علشان هي تنوع مصادر
دخلها هذا يحتاج استقرارا وامن لحدودها
ولكل المناطق الحيويه لانها القومي المجرى
المائي في البحر الاحمر مياه الخليج
العربي حدودها الممتده والمتاخمه لدول
كثيره والقريبه من سوريا طبعا اللي هي
موضوع حديثنا اليوم الامن ده يضمن لها
حاجتين الاول ان تتدفق يعني صادراتها من
البترول الى العالم الخارجي دون ان تتاثر
باي عمليات عسكريه او عمليه اضطرابات لانه
اذا تاثرت صادراتها تتاثر على عوائدها
الاقتصاديه واذا تاثرت عوائدها الاقتصاديه
من البترول تتاثر خططها
لتنويع مصادر اقتصاداتها لانه في النهايه
هي بتعتمد على مصادر البترول علشان تنفق
على مشاريعها الاخرى البعيده عن البترول
تحقيق الامن والاستقرار كان هدفا للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه ملحا في السنوات الاخيره
وخصوصا بعد اندلاع ثورات الربيع العربي
منذ اندلاسه الربيع العربي وجدت السعوديه
امنها واستقرارها وخططها واملها في تنويع
مصادر اقتصادها مهدده من عده مصادر المصدر
الاولاني طبعا الفوضى التي اعقاب الثورات
الربيع العربي والتي كانت يمكن ان تؤثر
على النظام السعودي وعلى الاستقرار
السعودي اتنين
تصاعد النفوذ الايراني ثلاثه السياسات
الامريكيه اللي هي لم تكن
يعني تطمئن المملكه ورغبه الامريكان في
الخروج من المنطقه
و عدم
وجود وعود ومعاهدات قاطعه من واشنطن بضمان
حمايه دول الخليج والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وعليه بدات السعوديه في مواجهه الاخطار
التي يمكن ان تهدد استقرارها وبالتالي
املها في ان تظل دوله ذات رفاهه
غنى يعني
تواجهها ازاي مرت بمرحلتين من 2011 و12
اللي هي اندلاع الثورات الربيع العربي
وحتى نهايه 2020 في السنوات دي ساعه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لمواجهه هذه
الاخطار باستخدام الوسائل الخشنه والقوه
العسكريه وده اتكلمنا عنه كتير ويمكن ان
نتحدث عنه بوقت لاحق السعوديه رايناها في
صوره لم نراها من قبل شفنا السعوديه
بتستخدم القوه بنفسها وليس عن طريق يعني
حلفائها الولايات المتحده او حلف شمال
الاطلسي استخدام القوه في مثلا اعاده
الاستقرار في البحرين اللي كانت مهدده من
جانب محتجين هي اعتبرتهم بيمثلوا المصالح
الايرانيه ويهددون نظاما سنيا حليفا لا في
البحرين
شفنا المملكه العربيه السعوديه بتتدخل
عسكريا في اليمن ضد الحوثيين وضد النفوذ
الايراني من وجهه نظرها بدايه من 2015
شفنا المملكه بتتدخل لدعم الجماعات
المعرضه بالمال والسلاح لاسقاط بشار الاسد
وعلنا شفنا المملكه بتحاول التخلص من بعض
المعاردين اللي اعتقدت انهم يمثلون اجندات
تسعى
[موسيقى]
يعني ضرب الاستقرار السعودي في الداخل وده
كان ابرز هؤلاء طبعا هو الصحفي السعودي
جمال خاشقجي الذي تم تصفيته في قنصليتها
في اسطنبول
احتجاز رئيس وزراء لبنان اللي هو سعد
الحريري لايام اكثر من عشره ايام او
اسبوعين
والاحتجاز ده كان وصف اللبنانيين لما حدث
لدعوه سعد الحريري الى الرياض ونفس الوصف
استخدمته فرنسا ودول اخرى لكن السعوديه
بتنفي انه كان احتجازا وهذه قصه يطول
شرحها المثال ايضا البارز اللي هو مقاطعه
وفرد ما يشبه الحصار على قطر مع دول اخرى
هي مصر والبحرين والامارات من 2017 وحتى
نهايه 2020 وهكذا
وطبعا مواجهه ايران على ساحات مختلفه
بوسائل مختلفه بدايه من اخر 2020 بدات
السعوديه تتغير وبدات تفكر في وسائل اخرى
لتحقيق نفس الاهداف ايه نفس الاهداف ان
انا احقق استقرار وامن
يساعدان في ان انا احقق اهدافي في
الازدهار بحيث ان تتدفق صادراتي بامان وان
انا استطيع ان استخدم عوائد البترول لتنوع
اقتصاداتي ويعني
بناء مشاريع اخرى لها علاقه لها بالبترول
وبدات تستخدم الديطان تشهد فتره يعني فتره
تهدئه مع الخصوم بدا ذلك واضحا مع الايام
الاولى من عام 2021
بالمصالحه شبه المفاجاه مع قطر
لغير المراقبين ودي قصه اتكلمنا عنها كتير
قبل كده ممكن ترجعوا لها في حلقات سوف اضع
لكم روابطها ثم بدات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في تحسين علاقتها مع تركيا بعد
سنوات من التوتر وزاره ولي العهد السعودي
انقره في 2022
وكانت المفاجاه الكبرى في 10 مارس 2023
بالاعلان عن نجاح وساطه
صينيه في اعاده العلاقات بين البلدين خلال
والمنتظر ان تعود العلاقات كامله خلال
اسابيع قليله قادمه في الاطار ده بياتي
خطوه التطبيع مع سوريا اي لنفس الاسباب
التي دعتها لاعاده العلاقات مع ايران لكن
اعاده العلاقات مع سوريا ليس هدف في حد
ذاته يعني بمجرد اعاده العلاقات بلن يحقق
الاهداف السعوديه الراغبه في استقرار
الاوضاع وبالتالي تمكنها من الحفاظ على
مصالحها الحيويه في على اراضيها او في
المناطق الحيويه لها في مطالب هي سعه ان
هي تحققها بالقوه في سوريا فشلت في
تحقيقها بالقوه في سوريا وبالتالي بتسعى
لتحقيقها بالدبلوماسيه ولذلك هناك مجموعه
من المطالب اللي بت السعوديه من بشار
الاسد
وبتطلبها الدول العربيه اخرى كانت وما
زالت تشارك الرياض وسعه الاقناع الرياض
بانه التفاوض هو افضل حل للحصول على هذه
المطالب دول زي مين بتشارك الرياض الاردن
الامارات البحرين مصر وقبلهم دول زي
الجزائر العراق الدول دي كلها عندها مطالب
واضحه من بشار الاسد وهذه المطالب تعتبر
شروطا واضحه للمضي قدما في عمليه التطبيع
التي يتم التفاوض عليها الان
التسريبات كتيره بخصوص الشروط
والاستريجيرنال سربت كثيرا من هذه المطالب
وشروط مجله المجله السعوديه اجرت اكثر من
تحقيق جيد لتسريب المفاوضات السوريه
العربيه لكن الحقيقه ومع وافر الاحترام
لكل هذه المنصات المحترمه جوهر ما سربوه
لا يعدو كونه مطالب منطقيه لا نحتاجه
لتسريبات لكي نفهمها ايه المطالب العربيه
طبعا كل دوله بتختلف عن الدوله الاخرى
ولكن نقدر نقسم المطالب العربيه الى
مجموعه من مجموعه من الفئات البسيطه اهمها
وابسطها فهما المطلب الامني الدول دي كلها
بتطلب من سوريا ضبطا لحدودها وبالتالي
السيطره على اي عمليه انفلات لجماعات
الارهابيه او هو يعني التنظيمات الاجراميه
واهم هذه الانشطه المزعزعه لاستقرار هذه
الدول هي طبعا تجاره المخدرات وتحديدا
تجاره الكبتاجون هذا العقار الذي يتم
تصنيعه بكثافه في الاراضي السوريه ويدر
على من يصنعوه عشرات المليارات من
الدولارات سنويا دول معادله بشار الاسد
تقول ان الحكومه متورطه الحكومه السوريه
بتنفي في كل الاحوال هناك جماعات على
الاراضي السوريه تصنع هذا العقار وتصدره
لكل دول الكوار الاردن العراق المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وغيرهم وبالتالي بات هذا
العقار صداعا في راس هذه الدول وهذا هو
المطلب الاول وهو ابرز المطالب ويبدو انهم
قطعوا شوطا كبيرا في تحقيقه حتى الان ان
نجحت المساعي
مساعد تطبيع اثنين مطلب انساني لكن في
جوهره هو في الحقيقه مطلب سياسي المطلب
الانساني ده ان تسمح دمشق بتدفق المساعدات
لكل من يحتاجها في سوريا سواء يعيشوا تحت
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها النظام او في
المناطق التي لا يسيطر عليها النظام هذا
مطلب انساني في شكله وهذا مهم لكن في
جوهره ايضا هو تمهيد لاعاده ملف
تمهيده لاعاده اللاجئين السوريين في الدول
الاخرى وهذا هو الملف الاكبر الذي يشغل كل
هذه الدول انت عاوز تنتقل الى القضيه
الكبرى وهي اعاده ملايين اللاجئين
السوريين اللي بيمثلوا عبء على الاردن
وعلى لبنان
ويخلقون العراق وطبعا يقلقون دولا غير
عربيه مثل تركيا ازاي انت
تنتقل الى هذه الخطوه وبالاساس الناس اللي
بتعيش في سوريا بيعيشوا في ظروف بالغه
الصعوبه يبقى لازم الاول نحسن اوضاع
السوريين داخل سوريا قبل ان ننتقل الى
الملف الاهم وهو ملف اعاده اللاجئين
وده ايضا مطلب اساسي من النظام السوري انه
يبدا يمهد الطريق لعوده امنه لهؤلاء
لملايين اللاجئين
زي امهد لهم الطريق تفاصيل كثيره لكن
خلاصتها انه يقطع على نفسه تعهدات بتوفير
عوده امنه لهؤلاء اللاجئين دون ملاحقات
امنيه او ممارسات انتقاميه او معاقبتهم
بالسجن مثلا للتخلف عن الخدمه العسكريه
التي كانوا يتهربون منها ويعترضون عليها
وفي كل الاحوال سوف يتم وقف اطلاق النار
في المستقبل كما تخطط هذه الدول وبالتالي
لن تكون هناك ضروره ملحه لاجبار بعض
السوريين على الالتحاق بالخدمه العسكريه
النظر بقى في الملفات التفصيليه الكثيره
اللي هو يعني اعاده ممتلكاتهم يعني على كل
الاحوال بصفه عامه ملف اعاده اللاجئين لان
ده ملف شائك ولا يمكن ان يكون سهلا كما
يبدو يعني
ثم الانتقال الى الملف السياسي وده ملف
خطير جدا خلاصته بدء التسويه الدائمه
للازمه السوريه اللي بقت عندها رميفيكيشنز
او اثار متعدده على كل دول العالم
الحل السياسي ده معناه باختصار انه سوريا
تبدا تتفاوض مع
المعارضين مش معقوله تستقر الامور في
سوريا والنظام في خصام مع ملايين السوريين
التفاوض ده معناه انه نبدا في لقاء مع
رموز المعارضه بصدر مفتوح ننظر في مطالبهم
ثم يبدا رحله طويله لاعاده
التنظيم كتابه الدستور تنظيم الانتخابات
انتخابات ينافس فيها الجميع طبعا ده على
الامد البعيد لكن في الاثناء وهذا ما يهم
هذه الدول هو الاتفاق على وقف اطلاق النار
بين القوى المعارضه النظام ثم دعوه النظام
هم بيدعوا النظام ان يدعو كل القوى
الاجنبيه للخروج من سوريا طبعا دي قصه
ليست سهله لانها تصطدم بمصالح تركيا
وتصطدم بمصالح الروس وبين مصالح
الامريكانو بمصالح الاتراك لكن على الاقل
يبدا النظام السوري يتفاوض مع كل هذه
الدول للخروج وما يعني الدول العربيه
تحديدا بصراحه هو خروج
الايرانيين بالدرجه الاولى وخروج الاتراك
بالدرجه الثانيه كل دي مطالب كلها صعبه
لكن بيجري التفاوض عليها في المقابل بشار
الاسد اللي مطالب بكل هذه القائمه الطويله
من الشروط عنده اهداف واضحه جدا انا في
امس الحاجه الى دعم عربي
لتقديم مساعدات اقتصاديه باسرع وقت ممكن
ليس فقط لاعاده اعمار سوريا التي هدمت
تقريبا بالكامل
ولكن من اجل يعني
التوفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه لملايين
السوريين اللي بيعيشوا في ظروف بالغه
الصعوبه اذا استمرت هذه الظروف الصعبه من
الصعب جدا على النظام على الرئيس بشار
الاسد ان ينعم باستقرار يمكن ان ينتصر في
حروب لكن لا يمكن له ان يهنا
ويظل على راس السلطه في بلد معظم الشعب
فيه جائع
يعني فقير ويعاني من مشكلات في الحصول على
ابسط الخدمات الانسانيه او الاحتياجات
الانسانيه
اثنين انه الدعم العربي ده معناه دعم
لشرعيته بشكل مباشر وليس غير مباشر لان كل
الدول ديت ان هي طبعت معهم
واعلنت رغبتها في التطبيع الان ثم بدات
تطبيع ياتي تباعا هذا الدعم لشرحيته
والتاكيد على ان بشار الاسد حقق انتصارا
عسكريا وانتصارا دبلوماسيا وكل من قاطعه
عاد ليتودد اليه ويتفاوض معهم ثلاثه الدعم
العربي ده معناه انه بيحمل ضمنا تعهدا
عربيا بالتفاوض مع الدول الغربيه اوروبا
الولايات المتحده لتجميد العقوبات
المفروضه على بشار الاسد وبالتالي يبدا
فتح الملف الاكبر وهو اعاده الاعمار في
سوريا
هذا هو مخطط المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومخطط الدول اللي بتؤيده مثل دول اخرى
تؤيده دول اخرى مثل الاردن اللي هي صاحبه
مبادره خطوه خطوه ودي قصه نبقى نتكلم عنها
بعدين ومصر والعراق والجزائر الى اخره لكن
هذه الرغبه والحماس في اعاده التطبيع مع
بشار الاسد بتصطدم بتحفظ مجموعه من الدول
لكل دوله اسبابها الخاصه باختصار شديد
المغرب مثلا قالت لا يمكن ان اقبل
بالتطبيع واعاده العلاقات مع سوريا الا
اذا اعلنت وتعهدت بقطع علاقتها بكبهه
البوليس واقرت بسياده المغرب على الصحراء
المغربيه الحكومه اليمنيه المدعومه من دول
الخليج بتشترض لكي تطبع مع بشار الاسد ان
يوقف دعمه
للحوثي وحلفائه في اليمن
قطر هي الاعلى صوتا في رفض عوده العلاقات
مع سوريا
وقطر يعني اسباب كثيره كل محلل بيحاول ان
يجتهد في فهمها لكن يبدو ان فيها بعد شخصي
القيادات القطريه كما اخبرني احد يعني
المطلعين على السياسه الخارجيه القطريه لا
يحبون بشار الاسد هناك ود مفقود بين
الساسه القطريين وبشار الاسد
مصالحهم لم تتحقق بل تضررت وهو مستثمروا
كثيرا يعني في دعم الجماعات المعارضه ضد
بشار الاسد لا يريدون ان تضيع كل هذه
الاستثمارات بلا اي مقابل ويعود بشار
الاسد كما كان
هذا يعني امر يؤذيهم
لكن انا في تقدير ان اهم سبب للموقف
القطري وهي مساله تحتاج الى حلقه كامله هو
المحركات الاساسيه للخارجيه او للسياسات
الخارجيه القطريه قطر كانت وما زالت راغبه
في ان تكون الدوله مستقله عن جيرانها
وخصوصا المملكه العربيه السعوديه وده كلام
تحدثنا عنه قبل ذلك وسوف اضع لكم رابط
الحلقه ماذا تريد قطر ويمكن ان نتحدث عنه
في وقت لاحق قطر لا تريد ان تكون دوله
تابعه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه ولا
لغيرها
ومنطقها يقول
قطعنا بشار الاسد سويا لاسباب مفهومه
ومولنا الجماعات المعارضه الراغبه في
اسقاط بشار الاسد وليس من المنطقي بمجرد
انا غيرت رايك يا ايها الساسه في الرياض
ان نغير راينا ونغير دفه الامور كلها من
اجلكم اذا انتم اردتم ان تغيروا بدون شروط
مسبقه نحن نريد شروط مسبقه ويعتقدون ان
الشروط المسبقه اللي هي تعهدات من بشار
الاسد باصلاحات سياسيه
ومراعاه طبعا المعارضه والكشف عن مصير
المفقودين والسجناء الى اخره هذه مساله
مبدا
ما تنسوش كمان انه هذا الموقف بيتماشى مع
الموقف الامريكي وقطر حريصه ان تكون
علاقتها بالولايات المتحده اقوى من اي
دوله خليجيه اخرى وهي وان ووعت علاقتها
الخارجيه لكن تظل على عكس مثلا الولايات
المتحده والامارات راغبه في الا تخاطر
ابدا بعلاقه مهتزه مع الولايات المتحده
والغرب ودي قصه محل اجتهاد احنا بنفسر ولا
نملك يعني طبعا
وثائق بتكشف لنا بدقه حقيقه موقف كل دوله
اما الموقف المصري فالحقيقه يعني يبدو
للبعض مربا قليلا لانه كان المتوقع ان مصر
يكون لها موقف واضح جدا في دعم عوده سوريا
الى الجامعه العربيه لكن مصر بدا موقفها
خافتا مترددا ليس بهذا الوضوح على الاقل
امام الكاميرات تقدير المتواضع انه الموقف
المصري يشبه الموقف الجزائري الموقف
السعودي الموقف الاماراتي وهو رغبه رغبه
مصريه في عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه
والتطبيع مع باقي الدول المنطقه
ولكنها تفضل ان تفعل ذلك
او يعني بنفس هادئ وبدون اتخاذ مواقف حاده
مصر بصفه عامه في السنوات الاخيره لا ترغب
في اتخاذ مواقف خارجيه حاده الا في
استثناءات قليله جدا
التفسير ان لها مصالح كثيره سواء مع دول
الخليج او مع اوروبا او الولايات المتحده
والقوى الاخرى اللي هي ضالعه في الملف
السوري تركيا روسيا وهناك اولويات متناقده
لهذه الدول مصر لا تريد اغضاب ايا من هذه
الدول باتخاذها مواقف حاده حتى لا تخسر
تاييد ودعم هذه الدول في الاولويات
المصريه الاكثر الحاحا اللي هي مساعدات
اقتصاديه
ودعمها في
الازمه الكبيره او الخطر الخارجي الاكبر
اللي هو الخطر الاثيوبي على مياه النيل
وبالتالي تفضل ان تعبر عن اولوياتها بشكل
هادئ بعيدا عن المواقف اللي هي شديده
السخونه والوضوح
هذه هي ماخذ الدول طبعا بالنسبه للكويت
الكويت لا اعتقد ان عندها مشكله في عوده
العلاقات عام بشار الاسد ولكنها تفضل ان
يتم ذلك عن طريق الاجماع
الكويت ان تضغط مجموعه من الدول
وتنجح في اعاده سوريا لجامعه الدول
العربيه بدون عدد كافي من اصوات الدول
العربيه
فتنجح هذه الدول في تحقيق رؤيتها ولكن
يؤدي ذلك الى خلافات اكبر بين اعضاء جامعه
الدول العربيه وينسحب ذلك على قضايا اخرى
يبقى صلحنا مشكله
سوريا وعملنا شقاق في ملفات اخرى هذا هو
الموقف يعني في حدود يعني ما تبينه لي
والمفاوضات بتجري على
هذه القضيه من خلال وجهات النظر المختلفه
انا عرضتها لحضراتكم لكن اذا نجحت اذا
نجحت الدول المتحمسه والاقرب انها سوف
تنجح يعني حتى هذه اللحظه في اقناع الدول
المتحفظه بفتح ابواب التفاوض مع سوريا اذا
حدث ذلك فسوف تكونوا عوده سوريا لجامعه
الدول العربيه
وتطبيعها مع بعض الدول هو الخطوه الاولى
في مشوار طويل جدا جدا لان هناك الكثير من
الالغام والملفات الساخنه التي يجب على
سوريا ان تحلها مع كل هذه الدول والحل ليس
كله بيد الرئيس بشار الاسد لان هناك اقطاب
عدد من اقطاب نظامه يجب اقناعهم اولا هناك
مصالح متضاربه لدول لديها مصالح ونفوذ
كبير جدا على الاراضي السوريه بل تكاد
تكون تحتل سوريا زي تركيا زي ايران زي
الولايات المتحده زي روسيا لنتابع
التطورات الملف السوري وان شاء الله يكون
لنا معه حلقات اخرى باذن الله اشكركم والى
لقاء